WOJTEK KALICINSKI: You know how
sometimes your phone battery
dies, and you plug your
device in for the night
but fall asleep before
it finishes booting?
Then you wake up an hour
late because your alarm clock
didn't work.
What if I told you that
you can save your users
from this disaster by
enabling your apps to run
in the new Direct Boot mode?
Direct Boot is available on
supported devices with API 24
and up, and it lets applications
run in a limited environment
right after their device boots
before the user has a chance
to unlock it for the first time.
There are a couple
of changes you
will have to make to your
app to support Direct Boot.
But before you start,
first take a moment
to decide whether your app
should run during this mode.
The best candidates
are apps that
provide timely and important
notifications, like alarm
clocks or messaging clients.
Another use case will be
applications that implement
accessibility services.
In any case, once
you've made the decision
to support Direct Boot,
the next thing to do
is figure out which
components of your app
will run before unlocking.
Only components that
you explicitly mark with
directbootaware=true in the
manifest will be eligible
to run during Direct Boot.
You can listen for
the new action locked
boot completed broadcast
to schedule any jobs
or alarms that you need as
soon as the device boots.
Note that once the user
unlocks the device,
all apps will still receive
the Action Boot Completed
broadcast as usual.
If you want to directly query
the state of the device,
you can call user
manager is user unlocked
or listen for the action user
unlock broadcast from a running
component of your app.
And finally, the last step to
make your app Direct Boot ready
is to move any private
app data needed
by your Direct Boot
aware components
to the new device
protected storage area.
Now, the default
storage area for apps
is called the credential
protected storage.
This is the location
that is accessed
when you use all the file
APIs on the context object
and can only be decrypted
once the user enters
their credentials.
To be able to store and read
data during Direct Boot,
you have to get and use a device
protected storage context so
that any file related API
calls use the device protected
storage area.
If there is any data that
previous versions of your app
created, or which was restored
from automatic backup,
and you need to migrate it to
the device protected storage,
you can use one of
the helper functions
for moving shared
preferences and databases.
Remember to think
carefully about what
to store in the device
protected storage.
All sensitive user data,
like full message history,
access tokens, and
passwords, should
go in the credential
protected storage.
Only use the device
protected storage area
for any information
that is absolutely
necessary for your app to
work while in Direct Boot.
Direct Boot mode will be
enabled out of the box
by default on new
devices that come out
with API 24 pre-installed.
You can test Direct Boot now if
you own a Nexus 5x, Nexus 6b,
or a Pixel C. Go
into Developer Tools
and select Convert
to File Encryption.
A word of warning though,
this will wipe all data
on your device.
Remember, users are counting
on those timely notifications,
so build better apps by
implementing Direct Boot now.
And check out our playlist
for other new features
that we're introducing
at Android.